- Hi everyone, my name is Heinrich
and welcome to another coffee
break with Firm Learning.
I need to admit that
today I'm drinking tea,
but, you know, who cares?
Today's video is going to be a bit shorter
and the main reason for that is
that today I also did a livestream
of almost two hours, covering all kinds
of career questions that you had.
So I'm very happy because I
felt this was quite a success
and a great thing to interact
with you guys this way.
Thanks to all of you for
joining and asking questions
and if you have missed
it for whatever reason,
no problem because you
can find it on my channel.
I uploaded the whole video for you to see.
The video covers all
kinds of great topics.
I'm talking about MBB consulting,
how you get into a consulting firm
like McKinsey, BCG, or
Bain, how you can enter
other career fields, such
as industry or banking,
what it takes to get an internship
at an MBB consulting
firm, and as an intern,
what you need to do to get an
offer after your internship.
So these are just a couple
of topics I covered,
so really check out the video.
I trust it is highly
interesting and valuable
for many of you out there.
In this video, I'm talking
about how a Master degree
or an MBA can really transform your career
and why the GMAT is such an important part
of this whole process.
And I came up with this
video idea really reflecting
on the livestream that I just did
because many people were asking questions
that were something in the direction like,
"Okay, I have this university degree
"which wasn't that
great, my grades weren't
"that amazing, and while it's an okay job,
"I feel like I wanna aim much higher,
"I wanna do an even more ambitious career,
"maybe even join an MBB consulting firm,
"but what are my best chances to get there
'if I have only an
undergraduate university degree
"so far, which maybe wasn't that great
"and maybe I have or have
not some work experience,
"which maybe also isn't that great,
"at least measured against the standard
"of an MBB consulting firm or maybe also
"an investment bank or
a competitive position
"within a blue chip company."
So, as always, if you're taking any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm, and, of course,
subscribe to this channel as well
for more content on how
you can be successful
in the first years of your career.
And if you haven't seen
it yet, I also have
and Instagram channel
where I post new content
for you every single day.
There's a link to my Instagram below
in the video description and if you
just directly wanna look it up,
my Instagram handle is
@firmlearning as well.
So, how can a Master or
especially an MBA help you
to transition into the career
that you really want to
if the job that you're currently doing
or the work experience that
you're currently having
is just not what you really wanna do
or maybe you're already
working in a specific function,
maybe in finance for several years
and you're just not sure how to transition
and you're just not sure
how to move from there
into completely other
role that you wanna do?
And here, yes, an MBA can help you
because with the MBA,
you have the opportunity
to do that at a very prestigious program.
So if you wanna do that and you feel like
your current academic performance
maybe regard to grades,
but maybe also the university itself
maybe isn't as great
as you would wish for,
here with the MBA, you
have the opportunity
to now aim for a good and
highly prestigious program.
And if you're asking yourself,
"Well, what are the most
prestigious programs,
"what are the best MBA
programs out there?"
probably the "Financial
Times Global MBA Ranking"
is a good way to start, but
they rank the MBA programs
according to some
well-established criteria.
And if you want to learn
more about how the degree
in specific can help you
now to transition careers,
either check out my video
specifically for MBAs,
so I have a video that covers MBAs,
in specific, what the learnings are,
whether you should apply for that.
I will link the video somewhere above me,
so check it out if you
have not seen it yet,
and, of course, have a look
at the livestream as well
because there I also talk
about many of these things.
But let's just assume that an MBA
or also a Master program
really can help you
to make this career transition, especially
if you're doing this with one of
the most highly-ranked programs out there.
But now, of course,
you might ask yourself,
"Well, how do I get into
these MBA programs?"
So you maybe know that
I did my MBA at INSEAD
and now you might ask, "Well,
how do I get into INSEAD
"or into any of these programs,
"especially if maybe
my academic performance
"so far wasn't that amazing or maybe also
"the work experience
that I have done so far
"wasn't maybe there as probably
"these top programs can expect?"
And this is now where
the GMAT comes into play
and I know there is lots of
controversy around the GMAT.
Many people think that
it's just unnecessary,
that this is just an
annoyance that you need to do
to get into these programs, but I believe
the GMAT in may ways is an equalizer
and the reason for that
is that a high GMAT score
can very much overcompensate
many of other drawbacks
of your application profile
that you might have.
So even if your grades
maybe weren't that great,
maybe the work experience
that you have wasn't
that impressive, if your
GMAT score is really high,
this can overcompensate
many of these things.
So it can help you to level
the playing ground for you
to give you a true and
real shot into one of
the most competitive
MBA programs out there.
So why do these top business schools put
so much emphasis on the GMAT?
And probably the main reason
is that the GMAT score,
the average GMAT score of the class is
a quality signal for the
quality of this MBA program.
So many MBA rankings, the
average or the mean GMAT score
of a class is a factor in that ranking,
so if an MBA program has more people
with high GMAT scores, this can help them
to score high in the GMAT.
And from the perspective of a candidate,
if you wanna apply for MBA programs,
you know, check out all these GMAT scores,
and you were able to score high,
of course, you'd rather
wanna be in a class
with lots of other people who scored high
on the GMAT as well because the GMAT is
a good proxy for how well you will be able
to perform in a business context
and it is also correlated
with future career success.
This is exactly how the GMAT was set up,
why people developed the
GMAT in the first place.
So put lots of preparation into your GMAT
to score as high as possible
and if you score high,
this can really help you to get into one
of the most selective MBA
programs and if you're doing
one of these very
prestigious MBA programs,
this can help you
significantly in your career
and then also to do all
kinds of career transitions
that you might wanna do, but
do not get me wrong here.
Of course, I'm very well
aware that scoring high
on the GMAT is not easy
and I made a whole video
about how I prepared for the GMAT,
the tips and tricks and strategies
that I used to score above
700 on my personal GMAT exam.
If you haven't seen that yet,
also I have it included
here in a link above.
Check it out.
So yes, of course, it's not easy.
It's not easy to get
into the most selective,
most prestigious MBA
programs of the world,
but the point that I just wanna stress is
that the GMAT can really
help you to overcome
many weaknesses of your
profile of the past.
With a high GMAT, of
course, there's no guarantee
to get into all kinds of MBA programs,
but it will be a big help.
So if you're looking
to do that transition,
do an MBA and try to get an MBA
that is as selective, as
competitive as possible
in terms of the rankings,
and to get in there,
do a GMAT and try to score as
high as possible to get in.
This is just a little
reflection on the livestream
that I did earlier because
there were many people
asking questions in that direction.
I hope this is helpful
and insightful to you.
Please, if you liked the
video, hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe
to this channel for more
content on how you can
be successful in the first
years of your career.
Thanks to all of you for watching.
This was Heinrich from
Firm Learning, good-bye.